i just want to start by saying uh thank
you for making me laugh every saturday
uh
it's really great thank you thank you
that's very nice to hear
uh so jumping into why i get to talk to
you today um
what was it about this project that said
i want to be a part of it or was it sort
of you finally leaning into being a vip
client
i the things that really made me want to
do it i think are
imagining it in like a who framed roger
rabbit kind of world
um i love the idea of seeing 2d
animation mixed in with with live action
stuff and
that was a movie i loved visually so
that that excited me i loved tom and
jerry growing up
um i liked uh the violence of the
characters i thought that
felt um i don't know like they
they earned the violence and it was fun
but it was that was i don't know it was
a good outlet to see as a kid who was
sometimes violent with my brother um and
i really like tim story the director so
i
felt like oh i i'd like to see what he
does with this world
um and then and then as also as the cast
came together that was really exciting
they were all people i would love to
work with
it's funny you say roger rabbit because
when i was watching it i also
was thinking about roger rabbit and how
insane robert
zemeckis was in the 80s to try to pull
that off
you know oh my god i mean technically of
course it's a crazy
thing but also it's such a moment in
time that will never happen when you
watch that movie because they
unite the stars from you know like
disney
and i think warner brothers at the time
or the looney tunes and disney
and you would never see that today you
would never see people coming together
and saying you know what
humans society wants to see this and so
even if it doesn't make total financial
sense for us we will give it to people
and they will get to see what they want
that just never happens anymore and
there would be so many lawyers that
would stop that from happening
so to actually see those characters and
to see bugs bunny and mickey mouse
interact is just you can't believe that
happened
i agree it's for people that haven't
seen roger rob in a while you bring up
an excellent point
um about all of them coming together uh
yeah i'm curious uh
i heard about this worst man movie a
while ago you and p davidson
what's what's the status of that movie
and do you have a director
yes we do uh chris store is directing it
who um
also did rami the show rami i don't know
if you
uh seen that and and produced eighth
grade too and he's great
um so we're work getting the script into
shape now and i think as soon as we can
uh we have time from snl and uh
various covid protocols allow we're
going to get into it
one of my favorite things on snl is you
and michael when you read each other's
jokes
that the other person wrote and i am
curious how much are you actually seeing
those things for the first time
on the air uh a hundred percent i'm
seeing
uh all of them for the first time on air
it's very
uh it's really a pretty terrifying
moment
um it's thrilling in a way but also
uh terrifying and i don't i don't know
any other moment like that really on uh
where you're gonna be on record on live
television and not know what you're
going to say
and you feel compelled to say whatever
you see
and the worst moments are always the
lead up to that moment where you're in a
hallway
and you hear one of the writers say you
can't make him say that
oh my god like his life will be over
they'll kill him you know and you hear
that you don't know what it is and
you're like oh my god can someone please
talk jay out of whatever that was going
to be so that's that's the the scarier
part and i'll check in with him too and
i'll be like everything's gonna be okay
right and he'll be like
this was your idea or like you you you
volunteered
i was like oh god so it's it's a it's a
it's a real uh experience
i recommend it right i gotta go thank
you again for making me laugh
all the time all right thank you very
much thanks for watching i appreciate it